foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
recent advances in a lyophilized qpcr
reagents this webinar is a part of the
sixth annual laboratory automation
virtual event
I'm Angelina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
was help from Marie Stone of labyrinths
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and sponsored by
Thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information about Thermo Fisher
Scientific please go to
thermalfisher.com
now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click submit
in addition to asking questions we
encourage you to participate in three
poll questions in the middle of the
presentation
click on your answer when the poll
questions are displayed
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I now present today's speaker Dr Olivier
brickad Global Market development
manager at molecular biology at Thermo
Fisher Scientific
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
Dr bakard you may now begin your
presentation
good morning good afternoon good evening
everyone thank you for joining
um today I'll be talking about some of
the recent Adventists that a fellow
Fisher Scientific has done online for
his qpcr Regent and I was a weekend
support your conversation or essay
development first I'd like to take some
time and just go over very uh about what
is a physician and what why should we
consider live position in inverse type
of Officer development
uh liposition is a preservation uh
method and it's basically done by a
freezing a product that's in solution uh
the and then by supremation removing the
ice and just staying with uh I'm sorry
mass of that contain that product and
that's very stable
um that is a technique uh that is that
has been used uh very early on uh on on
food uh and so forth and but made this
way um
relatively recently in in drug induction
development process around the the 90s
um
however today it's it's really becoming
an emerging Trend um in the uh the the
molecular point of care essays uh for
for
um for different reasons but truly for
the for the the flexibility but
liabilization at all uh for the staff
office
um
and uh it's uh it's been mostly used or
recently used in uh in qpcr uh uh for
point of care essay
um and it'll be able to uh to really
reduce the uh
um the cost of uh of uh of uh
transporting was they say to the point
of care while still achieving retrograde
results with uh with uh was gpcr region
so there's uh no job performance
so while authorization beside what I
just said uh first of all it's uh um
it's a it's much more stable than any
other preservation uh method uh it's uh
it can distort room temperature uh which
extend the shelf life and stability
um that also uh increase the volume
that's available for the sample because
we don't have to have any kind of
preservative and so forth with just the
the the
sample itself and or agent yourself
um also a lot of enzymes that are being
delivered on the market content content
glyceros because dcos is not compatible
with rifleization
um and so um there's a there's a gap
between uh the enzymes our presented on
the market and the life registration
needs which is why
um some officials developed a lot of fly
already reagents that contain very
little resource but that while retaining
all their capacity preferences from
before the right position process
to start with our first sporting
question
um so if you want to take a a few
moments to and answer the questions if
you are currently planning or developing
a molecular diagnostic testing lifeless
format and what I really appreciate your
answer
quite hopefully you'll have the time to
answer that question
um just uh moving on and
um going back into our uh rtn QPS and
PCR enzyme and thinking about what
before thinking about life resection
really thinking about the enzyme and
really
um when we look at uh any type of essay
DSA is only as good against I mean for
enzymes doesn't perform correctly but
then the AC is not going to perform
correctly yeah
um the main consideration to think uh
when you think about enzymes are the
sensitivity of the possibility if the
the type of company convention lower is
better uh inhibitorians we don't want to
have any kind of foreign because of the
presence of an individual and also the
thermal stability because we mostly that
we mostly deal with uh with a PCR
workflow we have this wide range of of
temperature
um
so
now I'm going back to the to the lion
Radiance I mean the one that we are
developing there where we are keeping in
mind the the characteristic that made a
good enzymes and that has to be they
have to stay true before and after the
life the rifleization when the enzymers
always constitutes
um so we developed a large game of
offense and that have been specially
formulated for uh for Life resolution
application
and the uh keeping in mind the uh uh uh
PCR and qpcr workflow so we have uh
listed on that slide we have reverse
transcriptase we have uh DNA polymerase
and also we um we have isothermal
enzymes uh that can be applied uh for a
lamp or lamp application as they are
training right uh currently in uh in the
molecular diagnostic industry
um
those enzymes were being shown with our
RNG department has shown that they were
performing
um if not as well maybe better
um than um over over leading uh enzymes
after a physician or Constitution and uh
I just want to uh to show a couple of
examples here uh using um one of our
latest liorority enzyme which is the uh
liar Reggie superscript reverse
transcriptase One Step I'll take qpcl so
it's a one-step
enzyme that just wants you but
everything is can be liberalized
together
reconstituting can and the sample can be
added directly and the rtq PCR performed
which I showed here this is the
detection of uh two um two viral RNA one
for the flu virus one for the coronova
coronavirus cough II
um and the result of our enzyme are
shown on the left of the slide under the
the red colon as you can see compared to
three other suppliers and leading uh
one-step Arctic upcr enzyme our live
radians and perform as well if not
better in most cases in uh than the the
than the other ends are showing that
um all the life is in process I didn't
decade any kind of preferences and it's
still true to like its true performances
from for to begin with
um
will we also show
um that is the the same is true when we
look at difficult
um excuse me difficult uh samples to
work with like human human samples and
erosion uh using the same or one-step
rtq PCR uh detection of two uh or two
Gene like a beta glucose or acidase and
Asylum Lycra factor in human inhuman
samples using our white Library uh one
step article PCR and comparing that to
uh to the the leading uh enzymes after
the physician and reconstitution and as
you can see again on the left under the
red colon
um our laryn science platform at least
as well if not better than the when the
competition really showing that our
um our radi enzymes are performing the
way that they should be after the after
reconstitution
um
as I said um we are thinking about
um when um liiorate the enzymes
throughout the world workflow of
amplification
um and the isothermal application
um have been becoming more and more
predominant uh in the last couple of
years and we are developed um some like
already enzymes whether it's the DNA
primary is all geology enzymes fatally
already specifically for the arch lamp
or lamp workflow
um
the enzymes I just talked about don't
really care towards uh
um asset developers who want to create
their own Umbro uh essay but we also
have a wide yam a variety of uh
mastering exact are already ready and
like already based on document
technology
and we have a qpcr we have a West and
West Apache qpcr that uh all the all the
advantage of our our family fissure
scientific Methodist but they also lie
already
um
and to really complete the the workflow
uh we just launched last year last
summer a uh a consumable that is a
specifically designed for Life
realization uh it's uh it's the
armadillo 9612 PCR strip plates uh
actual PCR plates are very uh well
suited for uh for Automation and uh and
the liquid handling automation mostly
but um this uh ends with a plate as the
uh the feature that it can be uh snapped
into rows effects L8 uh Wells the strips
of eight ways Wells which allow the
flexibility uh to have a
so an essay that's being liabilized into
a 96 World format and then used in a
more much more uh flexible and less
wasteful Way by just napping rows and
using as well from us so really thinking
about the workflow of the ACA from uh
the manufacturing all the way to the end
user that might not need to use 96 well
essay every time
um and this plate has been specifically
shown to uh uh
um to be
umization uh
compatible and does not affect regions
that are being like the performance of
regions that are being lifers in in this
plate
um I'll pause again for our second our
second question and so if you can um
take the time to uh to answer
um that would be very appreciated uh the
question is which methods are you using
for your molecular diagnostic essay
whether it's r2q rtgp cell qpcr
isothermal amplification next gen
sequencing or any other
great thank you so much for your answers
um I'll I'll move on move away a little
bit from the the product itself that
what we're offering in this uh in this
type of application and really
um focusing more of what therm official
scientific wants to be for uh for you
not only wants to be a supplier but we
want to be a partner we really want to
um
to enable you to be successful in uh in
your project and your endeavors we want
to be there uh supporting your needs not
only from a product's perspective but
also from a uh uh and then Twitter
property a manufacturing or service and
support perspective
and
um that comes with uh throughout the
world the world Journey with by where
where can help evaluating you walk
through need we can work with you in
terms of understanding what you are
trying to achieve and all together from
them we can help with selecting the
right product from our portfolio we have
a very very vast portfolio that can be
sometimes darling but uh
our sales teams and and the product
teams are trained to help you select the
product that fits your need
um uh depending on on the on the goal
that you have in mind we can also if we
don't carry that product we can't help
with customers customizing the the
product we have a team of research and
development that is dedicated to
customized products if needed to
um uh when we when we work in
Partnership uh and also we can work with
Supply agreement licensing agreement and
so forth and very streamlining that's
that piece and also with the
manufacturing we we have manufacturing
capability that we can we can put at
your disposal or if you if needed to be
so we really want to be your partner
throughout the world the world process
from ID to commercialization
and simply be simply because we think
that
um through partnership and alliances we
can create more value we can we have
this uh beside Mantra one plus one equal
free in mind where we can bring
everything that thermosphere
representing is to the table whether
it's the um the strong brand the value
prop in the value proposition the
portfolio breath
um our Innovative Innovative scientists
uh are size and scale of manufacturing
and can really bring that to the tables
really to support you and and build
value for for you as you go through the
for the commercialization journey
um and let's not forget firm official
scientific is a company that's of
scientists that also want to support so
we're bringing a vital vast scientific
experience knowledge and R2 that can
help you throughout from RNG to
verification manufacturing we can we
also have regulatory knowledge that can
we can put uh on the on the table as
well to really support you and also with
the conversation so we really want to be
your strategic partner not just a
supplier but a strategic partner to ear
on your journey to be successful in your
commercialization need
um and because of that uh very strong uh
uh world to be your your strategic
partner we're just launching this month
uh a new program the Monica dynastic
essay developer program that really
Target
um the uh
smaller or mid-sized uh asset developer
to really provide them the support that
they need to go through all the orders
at conversation process uh uh involved
and really at the feasibility and
development really early on we want to
be with you to help you uh be successful
from the beginning and not fail very
early on and and being successful
throughout
um
what is this program it's a it's a
program that is a is free prong one we
have discount pricing so
um to really help you with costs and
also make sure that you have the product
and you have the profile you'll have the
the the the work the product for your
for portfolio all together in a in a way
that makes sense and we can work with
that on with you also
dealing with multiple multiply supplier
when it comes down to commercialization
uh it can be very daunting so we want to
streamline that we want to offer
multi-site side layer let's just make
sure that all the
the late contract part is being taken
care in a very simple and very
streamlined fashion or to save addict on
the road and we also have ceiling
programs that offer instrument rentals
and and a variety of over over uh perks
um so think about this program in mind
if you uh if you have any type of of a
project that are gearing up to us common
series commercialization
and it's now time for our last question
um speaking of asili Romania we just
wanted to uh see if we will be
interested to be contacted by one of our
business development manager to discuss
any further uh I'll pause there for a
few a few seconds so you cancel that
question thank you
great thank you so much for your answers
um if a regardless of what you have your
answer to the last question if you want
to be in touch with us and we can just
to discuss uh your need and how can we
be your partner uh you can always
contact your business the development
manager at any time uh there are um yeah
they are here to support you uh or you
can just visit our
website.com OEM Dash inquiry and it'll
be a slew of information or can we
support you and also a point of contact
to uh to reach us
um I just now want to thank you for your
attention uh I hope that you enjoy the
talk and that will be partnering very
soon in your in your conversation
project thank you
thank you Dr bakrad for your time today
and your important research before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today I'd also like to thank
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
sponsoring today's webinar questions
submitted today and during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until May 18 2024. library to
alert you via email when it's available
for replay and we encourage you to share
that email with any of your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye